And what we need to make a network work is
a Protocol. And what a protocol is, a set of rules
that people agree to, that tell you how two entities
can talk to each other. So, for the web, the protocol
gives rules about how a client and a server talk
to each other. The client is the web browser and the
server, is the web server. So that might be udacity
dot com. The web browser is what you're running at home.
And what the protocol says is, if you want to
get the server to do something, the client has
to send a message in a particular way. The
protocol that we use on the web, is called hypertext
transfer proto, protocol. Which is abbreviated as HTTP. When
you look in your browser, almost all the URLs that
you use start with HTTP. That indicates that the
protocol, that you should use to talk to the sever,
that you're requesting a document from, is this protocol, called
hyper text transfer protocol. An it's a very simple protocol.
There aren't, too many messages. There's actually only two main
messages and there is only one, we'll talk about. That's
the message called GET. The client can send a message
to the server, where the message says get, and then
the name of that object that you want to get.
So that's all the client does. It sense the message
like this, and if you remember the python code for get
page. Well, let's call in some library function that actually does
this. That's sending the get message to the server. The server
will get that message. It will do some, run some code
on it. It will find a file that was requested. It
might run some more code to get the result. Take the
web application course to understand more about what the server does,
but what matters to the client, and what matters to us
in using this, is what happens after that. The server
sends back a response, which is the contents of the
requested object. So that's the whole protocol, that's what's going
on whether you send a web request using your browser, by
clicking on a link. Well then the browsers doing a
lot of things to figure out what you requested and then
its sending a get message to the right web server.
That was the server specified by the URL, to know which
server it is, and then its getting a response and its
doing processing on that response to render it. If you want to
understand more about what the web browser is doing, take the
programming languages class that focuses on how to build a web browser.